so today
I want to talk to you about
malware detection and what are what have
been the trends in
malware detection both in the academic
community and in industry
and I won't in particular to talk about
how we came to use machine learning for
malware detection as you may be aware of
machine learning has had a big
revolution in the past few years it's
very prevalent in a multitude of domains
like there have been great progress in
image recognition face recognition these
Technologies are in our phones but also
like both text translation and uh
topic identification techniques or even
text generation we've seen many recent
breakthroughs even in the past few weeks
however it's not as much widespread in
the security industry and this has been
researched in this academic Community
also for about
I would argue more or less more than 10
years so the question is like why isn't
uh especially in the context of malware
detection why isn't machine learning as
widespread in industry
the key point is that security is an
adversarial context by Nature at
attackers will try to evade detection so
they will try to fuse them evade the
machine Learning System like if we want
to represent it in a more formal terms
let's say that the benign applications
follow a certain distribution
and if the attackers develop something
malicious it follows another
distribution and
let's say that
antivirus companies can identify a
certain threshold to distinguish between
benign and malicious the problem comes
when attackers want to mimic benign
Behavior so that it creates a confusion
between what is benign and what is
malicious and it is not able to
distinguish them anymore
but this is not a problem just
necessarily in security and in malware
detection it can be in any domain like
even computer vision and it depends on
more about the threat model and what
you're looking at and that's why you
also both Academia and the industry have
been working into understanding
properties of robustness of machine
learning in a plethora of domains but
today I want to talk more about uh more
specifically about malware detection
and I want to start uh with uh
um I mean I want to actually use as a
writing example more of the mobile
applications because uh malware can take
different forms and general malware is
any malicious software that does
something to compromise the
confidentiality Integrity availability
of or privacy of a user or a system
and while malware can take many forms
like uh it can be a Windows PE a
JavaScript plugin it can be
like a dll but uh it's easy to think of
it as like a mobile application is
self-contained and it's easier to think
about it as a as a case study so let's
say that
while an antivirus company and we want
to evaluate whether a certain
application is benign normal issues so
what is the first thing that we do well
first of all we do some static and
dynamic analysis static economic
analysis derived from compiler Theory
even it's like there are very basic
computer science knowledge and for
example Dynamic analysis is based on
principle of debuggings and certain
breakpoints in course so most of you may
be familiar with it but the intuition is
like to get a representation of the
behavior of an application static
analysis evaluates an application
without executing shooting it so it's a
static evaluation of the code
and this is often there are a variety of
techniques often from the field of
program analysis that try to evaluate
the code and possible branches or state
representations and there are behaviors
for it this is kind of like what might
this do yes exactly but of course there
are like different levels of precisions
that you may achieve static analysis can
also be very lightweight it can be just
even uh
counting the API calls that are present
in a certain piece of software of course
that is not a very relevant uh it does
not describe any complex Behavior per se
so it's a very likely static analysis
but the quick system of certain apis can
still reveal that something malicious I
mean that it may identify something that
is common also in other malicious
applications
and dynamic analysis on the other hand
is kind of comp to complement it it's
more like an actual execution of the
application so it executes the app and
generates an execution trace and as I
told you uh it's it's based off
debugging principle it's like inserting
a lot of breakpoints and monitoring the
system calls and taking the arguments
and again you can have different levels
of precisions also here
um of course the more Precision you want
to have the more expensive is uh become
the analysis becomes
and
in Dynamic analysis you get the behavior
of an actual execution of the
application so it has the benefit over
static analysis of observing real
Behavior think about even a social
network app and maybe there are parts of
the social network app that are even
never reached right or are not very
commonly used
of course a problem that is typical of
dynamic analysis is like stimulation
right it's like you need to simulate
what the users would do like to provide
a proper coverage of the application in
a sense Dynamic analysis provides an
under approximation of an application
Behavior because it's like just an
actual execution where a static analysis
provides an over approximation maybe
there are some areas of code that will
never hardly be reached in an actual
execution
but still maybe you give importance to
them indeed one strategy that attackers
use
to complicate this type of
to complicate that action that they're
doing something malicious is to add a
lot of junk code that is maybe then
taken into account into static analysis
and then you end up with very complex
abstract syntax trees or control flow
graphs and it makes it very complex then
to distinguish what is actually going on
and what the application is doing so
they might kind of put a lot of
libraries in for ADD no images or
something which it never uses but they
get added up and checked and oh this
this is just something to do with images
right exactly yes it's exactly like you
say it's uh they may insert a lot of
junk and actually one of the most common
techniques that are used nowadays is
like called piggybacking which you take
for example an app like a game app and
then which like 99 of the app is maybe
benign and then you inject something
malicious in it so it's it makes it even
harder to analyze and identify the
malicious part that is triggered so
static and dynamic analysis will be the
basis of malware detection regardless of
whether we use machine learning or
something else but what is this
something else that has been
historically used by antivirus systems
is like signature based detection let me
just write SBD typically antivirus
companies will have a database of
signatures that are like they can be as
simple as sequence of buys like that
that they have been found in malware and
if a signature match is found then
the application is detected as malware
otherwise it's just assumed that it's a
benign application but signatures can be
also more complicated they can be I mean
you can think of them as regular
expression they can even they can even
be like there are typically languages
um to like
explain or ex Express
signatures in more more complex
signatures like the camera should be
behavioral signatures about whether an
app is doing X and doing wide and doing
that then we have seen it in the past
it's a malicious app
the problem with the signatures-based
that action although this is still used
the problem is that it's a
time consuming of course attackers in a
sense work 24 7 to develop new
strategies to evade detection so it
becomes more
[Music]
it takes time for Defenders to come up
with the proper signatures that also
have the good amount of false positives
and false negatives right you don't want
to overlap with benign software detector
benign software by accident
and the database of signatures then
become more and more complex to maintain
because a there are prone like imagine
like uh if you I mean anyone that has
been work with regular expression it may
be the same like if you start having uh
just a set of keyword compositions that
can be used in a form let's say then it
the more keyword you start allowing I
mean of course let's say that you want
to express words as regular Expressions
right the more rules you start adding to
this form the more likely than you will
either exclude something that was
allowed before or include something that
should not be allowed
so where does this take us it takes us
like to then also using uh machine
learning as another way of detecting
malware it's still built off of static
and dynamic analysis so like it inherits
strengths and weaknesses of these
approaches
let's say that you could also like
especially with the rise of deep
learning and the many successes of deep
learning you can even ideally throw an
app inside the machine learning
algorithm or like a deep learning
algorithm so that it then learns
uh it's deep learning is representation
learning so it can learn automatically a
representation of the application and
its behaviors but I think that the
problem there is that uh
we do not I mean most of the neural
networks that we have nowadays are for
other tasks like for voice recognition
text understanding or text translation
or image recognition
they're not suitable to identify uh
program Behavior so it will just
identify superior's correlation and
treat the app as an image for example
so I think that it's it's very prevalent
yet
um to just
perform static and dynamic analysis and
Define uh with Ex human expertise
signatures that can express behaviors
back to the point like why is and
machine learning as popular in industry
for malware detection as it is for other
tasks
and one
big aspect is that since security is
adversarial as I pointed out before
malware evolves quickly over time so
like let's say an underlying Assumption
of machine learning is that training and
testing roughly follow the same
distribution of course machine learning
is about learning from data so actually
there's also a way of saying in the
machine learning community that it's
like garbage in garbage out like if you
have poor data representation in the
training set whatever the machine
learning algorithm learns will also be
useless for the tasks that you want to
solve in this case it's not necessarily
a garbage problem but it's more like
maybe you train from data from a set of
benign and malicious applications from
2019
but then attackers develop new
strategies and now
those apps are not representative
anymore of the current threat scenario
so malware evolution is really it's
often referred as concept drift as well
or like distribution shift in technical
terms
and uh
it's a real challenge for this domain uh
but it's not Also let's say we should
not like surrender uh there are
techniques even for the machine learning
community that can be adopted in these
cases like such as active learning
online learning or another intuition is
like classification with rejection
uh sorry like it's another approach like
the intuition is that you may for
example discard and quarantine decisions
that have
uncertain probabilities like in which
case like if we want to distinguish
between good or malware if if the
malware detection system tells that it
is an hour with 55 percent probability
while it most likely is I mean it's very
uncertain about it it's like very very
my I mean it's very very minor
likelihood that it's like a malware so
you may decide to quarantine and
threshold it right
so let's say uh and that actually this
is what what the security academic
Community has been working on as well
it's like trying to understand ways to
adapt and
to this drift and like understand how to
maintain a machine learning models
accurate over time people may think that
and also when I started working in this
field I also thought that okay there is
malware and there is a good order
clearly separate right but sometimes
it's not as clear you could debate that
without context certain applications
such as I don't know even an email
application or a social network
application could be just identified as
malware right so context is important
but yes also the different families
originally the families were like very
very distinct you had ransomware that
encrypts your data and that's for ransom
you add like spyware that wanted just to
steal your data secretly you had I don't
know
um
apps that maybe still Credence
specifically just credentials for bank
accounts but nowadays also the
categories have become also more merged
it's more typical that the malware does
multiple malicious behaviors at a time
uh because they want to achieve
different objectives and also over time
the same our family will change slightly
objectives
and this yes this is part of the reason
that complicates the whole detection yes
we talk about the more Revolution over
time
uh another thing that is very important
to consider is that
we cannot like so the attackers are not
blind if we start using machine learning
for detecting malware then they can also
take advantage of the fact that we use
machine learning
to further evade our system
and in a sense in adding as we add
machine learning as Defenders we
increase the attack surface for
our system because then the attackers
can Target this many people may have
heard about adversarial machine learning
and this is what this is about it's
become very popular in the image domain
where you have this image of a panda you
add a little bit of visually
imperceptible pixel perturbation which
is carefully crafted and suddenly the
panda by all machine Learning System is
detected as another animal in the more
detection domain
it the principle Remains the Same but
it's a little bit more complicated you
cannot just as in the image domain
randomly add bytes to the software it
will just not run and even something
simple that has made the news such as
adding a little bit of bytes at the end
of a file it's not sufficient because
even just compilers will remove junk
code or unreachable code or sometimes
it's called also that code it depends on
the type of technique but if the code is
clearly not reachable then it will be
just be discarded by the analogy system
so the attack will be ineffective
attackers need to may have objectives
such as preserving the malicious
functionality or making it plausible so
that for example it's not a torch app
that weighs like three gigabytes part of
the reason in which it was I think in
the early 2010s
um industry started you tried to use
machine learning as it is and then
nothing was working nothing was
explainable it wasn't reliable so there
was a moment in which it was completely
discarded but in that scenario I think
that the problem was that we should
avoid having a false sense of security
one thing that was very typical and
still is in the machine Learning
Community is to do careful
cross-validation so you divide your data
sets into faults in this example like
six volts then you use one full for
testing and that is for training and
then you rotate and the principle is
that you want to avoid picking a lucky
slice right you want to see whether your
approach generalized to different
conditions the problem in security is
that if you do this you are
in a sense
integrating future knowledge in the
training side you know like disregarding
the temporal separation that needs to be
present between training and testing set
right if you have like three new malware
families here that appeared just last
year by rotating you will integrate them
in the training set whereas if they come
later there should be temporarily
separators in your evolution in a sense
you should
should become more aware of in a sense
the do's and don'ts of machine learning
for computer security
and malware detection
and
use these techniques more appropriately
as I understand it when a machine
Learning System is very good at choosing
stuff it's been or identifying stuff
it's been trained on it's called
overfitting isn't it yes and is that the
big problem here because it's seeing
things that are new it's seeing things
it hasn't found yet in the wild after
it's been trained that's the problem is
is is there any point in doing this I
suppose is what I'm thinking if if
that's the big problem it's you know
identifying new stuff
yes so I I would argue that
[Music]
um
I think identifying new stuff
maybe has like a natural language
meaning and a more technical terms
meaning I mean there are like actually
when you say identifying your stuff
people would expect that it is able to
identify everything possible but at the
same time when I talk about this yeah
you can't see it as something similar to
overfitting in a sense it's related I
wouldn't say it's exactly the same thing
it is learning a lot from the training
data and people that may say but then
it's completely unable to learn new
things I think that truth is somewhere
in the middle in the sense that the
objective is to have a good static and
dynamic analysis that could give you
also the right
level of Behavior representation so it's
all about as many things in computer
science it's a lot about abstract
representations
so that that with machine learning you
can automatically learn uh what are some
key elements that represent actually
malicious behaviors this will allow them
to identify new variant social test time
because it will anyway recognize the
underlying patterns so
the thing is that in many cases
attackers just do the same thing in a
different way and I think this is the
key point and I think machine if machine
learning can help us understanding and
scaling to detecting the underlying
strategies of attackers then it can
generalize in a sense to identify new
threats the problem currently is that
with the representations that we have
they are able to just
change the do the same thing in such a
different way that the machine learning
will not be able to detect it so this is
actually the key problem here the Holy
Grail of malware detection is uh having
the right level of abstract
representation to identify malicious
behaviors
which will change this number and
hopefully increase it until that is the
category that is seen in the image and
not the giraffe so this this level will
go down and this one will go up
let's just write a very silly little
Python program so I can write this
function let me make a little bit of a
bigger font size for you